-So, Amy, you directed
"Wine Country".
That was with your closest "SNL"
friends, outside of yours truly.
But I'm wondering
what the experience was like
working with this young,
talented cast --
I'll show it again --
and your old friends.
-Oh, look at those cuties.
Well, I really, really had
great experiences on both.
I think with "Wine Country,"
it was a little more sisterly.
And I would guess
maybe in this film, "Moxie,"
I perhaps was
a little bit more maternal
But I don't know.
"Moxie," it's more dramatic.
And it kind of deals
with some deeper issues,
so there was a lot of
sensitive subject matter
and very thoughtful --
very thoughtful preparatio
and discussions from the cast.
In "Wine Country," I don't think
anyone even read the script.
[ Laughter ]
-Now, did they admit to you,
or would it be, over the cours
of the day, it would
slowly dawn on you that none
of them had read the script?
-Realize...
You know,
an actress would come up and go,
"Oh, so we're
supposed to be friends?"
[ Laughter ]
-Speaking of working
with friends, you and Am--
Excuse me. You and Tina
are hosting the Golden Globes.
How's prep for the Globes going?
-So good, Seth.
The prep is going so good.
We just have
a few final questions,
which is, when, how,
why, where, and what.
-Great.
-Just those --
That's all we need to find out
But we're going to
figure it out.
-I think it will be a tonic fo
all of us to see the two of yo
in whatever arena
it ends up being.
I'm looking forward to it.
I know you use time like thi
where a lot of people
are watching television
because you can't go out as much
to catch up on the latest
in television.
-Yeah.
-The most groundbreaking -
The TV, the films of today
What have you been watchin
the most?
-Well, I've been watching
this amazing new show.
I cannot recommend it highly
enough. Which is "E.R."
And I've been watching it
from top to bottom.
This is my third time throug
in my lifetime,
but this is -- and I can't -
I can't stop watching "E.R."
So now I'm into, like, the Wik
fandom of all the characters
And I'm spending all my time
just Googling, like,
"What happened to the surgeo
in season one?"
"Why did William H. Macy
not stay on 'E.R.'?"
"Was Eriq La Salle and Noah Wyle
actual friends?"
Like, I'm just so deep.
And, Seth, you know, people like
to talk about the cool thing
that are on Netflix or on HBO,
and that's great.
But Dr. Carter's journey..
is so good.
And at one point,
he's saving people in the Congo.
This show is so good.
-I'm glad you're giving
Noah Wyle his credit.
Because Clooney obviously,
Doug Ross, was everything.
-Clooney's the obvious reaso
why you --
You go for Clooney.
You stay for Noah Wyle.
[ Laughter ]
-Has Clooney's -- Has Clooney'
performance held up for you?
-I did have a moment
recently in --
I don't know what month
it was -- where I realized
I was maybe too lonely
and had been
quarantining too hard.
Because it was the middle of the
day, and I was in my pajamas
and I was watching, like -
I don't know --
re-watching
season three, episode ten,
where Clooney saves a kid
that's stuck in a water pipe
and he lifts him up
out of the water.
And I stood up and pointed
at the TV, and I said,
"And that's when
he became a star!"
[ Laughter ]
No one was home.
-You weren't wrong.
-No. No. That was it.
But, you know,
I'm at a point now, Seth,
where, look, we're very lucky.
We have fancy friends.
Sometimes -- I know you have
a lot of fancy friends.
And you are my fancy friend.
But I have a friend
who kind of --
you know, who knows
Julianna Margulies.
And I texted him,
and I was like --
You know, I was trying
to set some intentions
for things so that I can
look forward to doing things
once this lockdown is over
"Is there any way, maybe in th
summer or in the fall, when --
you know, when things
get less stressful and scary
that I could meet
Julianna Margulies
at a restaurant?
And ask her a list of question
I have about
Nurse Carol Hathaway,
her character that she playe
on 'E.R.' 20 years ago?"
And the friend was like,
"You know, um, I'll ask her.
[ Laughter ]
So I have --
I just want her to know
that I have a hard 50 question
waiting for her.
-I -- Look, I'm going to mak
sure the next time she's her
I lock down that date for you.
-Oh. That would be amazing
That would --
Do you --
Have you ever watched "E.R."
'Cause you're acting like
you haven't.
-Amy, they weren't lying whe
they called it Must See TV
-100%. 100%.
When I was shooting
"Wet Hot American Summer,"
a little gem
that we shot, like, 1999 -
before there were
cellphones, folks --
they used to have
these, like, TVs
that you could wear
around your neck.
And it was the episode
when Carol Hathaway went -
Julianna Margulies
went back to Clooney,
and somebody was watching it
on TV, running around, crying.
Like,
"She went back to Clooney!
I mean, those were the days.
-I remember --
I recently watched just
the last -- her last episode
Was that --- Is that the one
you're talking about
where you see Clooney
at the waterside?
-Yes, when she flies to Seattle.
She's like, "I have twins.
What am I doing?
I mean, I love Luka,
but he's not for me.
He's going to find..."
-Preaching to the choir.
[ Laughter ]
Well, I feel like we've done
a good job plugging a lot of
mid-to-late-'90s work
that took place in Chicago
-Yeah.
-"E.R.," "The Matrix,"
and Amy Poehler.
-I mean, when you --
when you think of me,
you think of, like,
what's next, what's new.
-What's the next big thing
I want to finish by saying
thank you for being here
and also that the third season
of "Making It" --
I love you, Amy -- premieres
later this year on NBC.
And Amy's film "Moxie"...
-Bye. I'll see you at home
-[ Laughs ]
...releases on Netflix
March 3rd.